اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه التغطيه المستمره
للنزاع المسلح الدائر في السودان جدل كبير
يجب ان عوده العسكريين المصريين الذين
كانوا محتجزين لدى قوات الدعم السريع في
مطار مروي شمال السودان فبعد ان اعلنت
وسائل الاعلام رسميه مصريه ان الدفعه
الاولى من المصريين عادت الى البلاد خرج
المتحدث الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
المصريه يؤكد ان العمل لا يزال مستمرا
لتامر عوده هؤلاء العسكريين الجيش
السوداني نفى ان تكون قوه الدعم السريع
سلمت العسكريين المصريين في مقاله الدعم
السريع انها سلمتهم جميعا
نحن سلمناهم جميعا لا ندري هل تم
تقسيمهم او احتفظت المصريه هنا بجزء منهم
ام لا لكن نحن سلمنا الطرق المصري كل
المصريين الذين بيدنا واخلينا كامله من
هذا الامر
وتنضم الينا من القاهره رنده ابو العزم
مديره مكتب العربيه في مصر اهلا بكرندا
يعني هناك لغه كبير حول يعني هؤلاء
العسكريين هل هم من قاعده مروي الذين
كانوا يتواجدون في هذه القاعده ام بمكان
اخر ايضا قوات الدعم السريع تقول سلامتهم
جميعا يعني جهات اخرى تقول لا ما حقيقه
الموضوع او المعلومات المتوفره
اولا راويه بحسب البيان الصادر من المتحدث
العسكري
وبحسب ما اعلن بالفعل ان وما رايناه في
احدى الصور ان هناك دفعه اولى من الجنود
المصريين اعادت الى ارض الوطن ساعه
الافطار وكان هناك هدنه
خلالها اجلاء هؤلاء الجنود العناصر التي
كانت مختلفه في السودان كدفعه اولى بطائره
مصريه هبطت على ارض الوطن اذا هذه نقطه لا
يمكن التشكيك فيها بيان المتحدث العسكري
ذكر ان
اكد فيه ان القوات المسلحه تجري جميع
التنسيقات مع جهات الاختصاص المختلفه
لتامين عوده كافه العناصر كافه العناصر
بمعنى ان من وصل كان جزء من العناصر وليس
كلها وبالتالي هذا لا يتنافى مع وصول جزء
بالفعل او دفعه اولى
واكد واعاده تاكيد مره اخرى على البيان
الذي كان قد اصدره في اليوم الاول ان هذه
العناصر كانت في مهمه تدريب مشترك مع
القوات السودانيه طبقا للبروتوكول الموقع
بين الدولتين وايضا هناك تاكيدات من حتى
وسائل الاعلام المحليه ومن المصادر
المصريه ان الرئيس السيسي بيتابع عن كذا
التطورات نقل القوات المصريه اذا
لا يوجد
تضارب في الانباء خاصه هنا في مصر نحن
نعلم ان هناك دفعه وصلت اما عن باقي
الدفعات اذا كانت هناك دفعه ثانيه او اكثر
من دفعه هذا ليس واضحا حتى الان ولكن كما
ترين ونرى على الشاشه ان اصوات اطلاق
النيران قد تعيق اي عمليات اجلاء حاليا من
تم اجلائه كان بالاتفاق وكان بهدنه بالفعل
تم الاتفاق عليها بين الطرفين المتقاتلين
بايقاف اطلاق النيران لحين هبوط الطائره
المصريه واقلعها مره اخرى تحمل هذه الدفعه
الاولى
هذه يعني معلومات نحن متاكدون منها اما ما
يتم الترشد فيه في السودان فهو مرايا يعني
على مدى الايام الماضيه تفضل هل من
معلومات خاصه بمصادرنا رنده حول الاجراءات
المتبعه الان بالقاهره ويتم العمل عليها
لتامين عوده كافه عناصر القوات المسلحه
نعم يعني ربما مصر هي الدوله الوحيده التي
نجحت في اجلاء او في هبوط طائره من
طائرتها في مطار الخرطوم
واجلاء عناصر كانت محتجزه هناك وكما علمنا
انه في الساعات الاولى من اليوم نجحت مصر
في الحصول
على السودانيه اليهود مؤ
قته 20 ساعه على اثرها تم الاتفاق بوقف
اطلاق نيران ومضادات الطائرات من قبل
اطراف السودانيه القاهره نفتقد بعدم
استهداف مسار الخرطوم منذ الفجر والجيش
السوداني ابلغ مسؤولين امنين مصريين فقط
بتسهيل مهمه النقل وعدم استهداف المطار
هناك حاليا اتصالات بتتم بين مصر والجيش
السوداني وايضا مع الدعم السريع
التصريحات التي ذكرتيها ان مسؤول الدعم
السريع ابلغه القاهره بالفعل انه لم يصبح
لديهم اي عناصر مصريه اخرى وجميعهم حاليا
غدر وغادروا نطاق القوات الدعم السريع
ولكن يتم ربما في الساعات القادمه بعد في
حاله ايقاف اطلاق النيران سيتم ابلاغهم
بالفعل راينا اول امس ان كان هناك اجتماع
لرئيس السيسي لمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
وفي هذا الاجتماع كان هناك اكثر من نقطه
تم التاكيد عليها اولا ان مصر لا تتدخل في
ما يحدث في السودان لان هذا شان اقتتال هو
هذا شان داخلي ولا تقف مع طرف ضد الاخر
وان هناك مبادرات مصريه ايضا رايناها
لايقاف اطلاق النيران لاسباب متعدده من
بينها ايضا اسباب الانسانيه وان تامين
عوده القوات المصريه وجنود المصريه التي
كانت هناك في تدريب مشترك هي كانت اولويه
وبحسب ما علمنا من مصادرنا ان كان هناك
اعطاء مهلك 72 ساعه العوده هؤلاء الجنود
كان بالامس من المفترض ان الهدنه التي
اخترق بالامس ان يتم
فيها نقل الجنود ولكن تم اختراقها وبالفعل
تم نقل دفعه اولى من الجنود المصريين
اليوم
في في خلال هذه الهدنه التي ربما لن تصبح
ساريه كما نرى على الشاشه
وبالتالي هل يمكن الحديث عن قنوات تواصل
مباشره ان كان بين القنوات يعني او الجهات
الرسميه المصريه مع قوات الدعم السريع او
حتى الجيش نعم نسر بتتواصل مع كافه
الاطراف منذ اللحظه الاولى وهذا يعني معلن
وسواء تواصل مباشر او حتى تواصل عبر
مصر ايضا بكثير في اكثر من مسار المسار
الدبلوماسي المسار السياسي وايضا مسار
التواصل المباشر كان هناك مبادره مصريه
بين رئيس السيسي ورئيس جنوب السودان
لايقاف اطلاق النيران هناك ايضا اتصالات
على مستوى بين الرئيس السيسي وبين عدد من
الاشقاء العرب وبين الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي لايقاف اطلاق النيران
هناك ربما وفود ستذهب ايضا الى الى
السودان في محاوله لوجود ايقاف اطلاق
النيران على الاقل فتره عيد الفطر راينا
الى جانب هذه الجهود المصريه نداء انساني
من الامين العام للجامعه العربيه لايقاف
اطلاق النيران وقت العيد اذا كل هذه
الجهود اضافه الى الجهود الاقليميه والدول
العربيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه وغيرها
ربما ستسفر عن يعني عن ايقاف ولو انساني
لاطلاق النيران في الفتره القادمه شكرا
جزيلا لك من القاهره رنده ابو العزم مديره
مكتب العربيه في مصر
[موسيقى]
ومن ضمن الجدل غير المحسوم ايضا الموقف
عند القياده العمل لوزاره الدفاع
السودانيه حيث تؤكد الدعم السريع انها
تحاصرها فيما نشر الجيش مقطع فيديو يؤكد
انه يبسط سيطرته على الموقع
[موسيقى]
الطعامه
الى ذلك رددت الاشتباكات في ام درمان
ومناطق اخرى في الخرطوم رغم الهدنه التي
وافق عليها الطرفان وكانت الاليه ثلاثيه
في السودان هي كل من الاتحاد الافريقي
والهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه المعنيه
بالتنميه والامم المتحده قالت ان اطراف
النزاع في السودان التزموا بالهدنه كما
ناشدت الاليه القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع تهيئه الظروف ليتمكن
المدنيون من تلبيه حاجاتهم الاساسيه من
ماوى وغذاء ورعايه طبيه بالاضافه لتاكيدها
على الوقف الفوري والدائم لاعمال العنف في
البلاد
هذا ويشكك اهالي السودان باستمرار الهدنه
بين اطراف النزاع متخوفين من خلقها ما
يسبب لهم القلق من الوضع غير المستقر في
البلاد
تحدثت الى العديد من الناس حول هذا
الموضوع ولا احد يشعر ان الهدنه ستستمر
بحلول الساعه السادسه رايت مروحيات عسكريه
تحلق في الاجواء وبالتزامن مع شهر رمضان
وصلنا لمرحله لا نعرف في اي يوم من الشهر
نحن عاده ما يكون رمضان مثل وليمه عند
الافطار ولكننا بالكاد ناكل لان كل شخص
يعاني من التوتر والقلق بسبب الوضع الحالي
مرحبا يعني
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه للشرق الاوسط احمد
المندري نشد الاطراف السودانيه الالتزامه
بالقوانين الدوليه مشيرا الى ان ما يحدث
في السودان اكبر من قدره الهيئات الصحيه
الاطراف المتنازعه الالتزام بقانون الدولي
المختص بهذا الموضوع وحمايه ارواح
المدنيين خلال هذه النزاعات لكن للاسف كما
هو معروف لا يغلب يعني صوت العقل خلال هذه
المحن والازمات وانما يغلب صوت السلاح
للاسف فنناشد كذلك يعني الجميع داخل
السودان ان يلتزموا بالاخذ الحيطه والحذر
وعدم الخروج الى الاماكن الخطره حتى
يضمنوا كذلك يعني التزام الاطراف
المتنازعه بالهده وبالتالي عدم تعرض
تعرضهم للمخاطر وفقدان الارواح الكثيره
[تصفيق]
يا لهوي
ما هنا يا جماعه
في اي حته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن الخرطوم بحري ينضم الينا الصحه في
عمان ابو شيبه اهلا بك سيد عمار يعني كيف
هو الوضع الان بالخرطوم بحري تحديدا هل
هنالك التزام كامل او جزئي بهذه الهدنه
يعني الاوضاع الان في مدينه بحري والذي
كانت تشهد عديد من الاشتباكات منذ الصباح
الباكر وحتى عند فتره الظهيره الان ربما
نشهد هدوءا حذرا وربما هنالك عديد من
الاصوات التي نسمعها بين الفيله والاخرى
بالاصوات اعيره الناريه ولكن توقفت
المضادات الارضيه التي كانت قبل
من الان اي بعض الافطار مباشره يبدو الوضع
حذرا جدا الحركه الداخليه للاحياء ايضا
بحذر التيار الكهربائي يعني كان مقطوعا عن
بعض الاحياء في مدينه بحري عدد الان تعمل
بشكل مباشر عديد من الاحياء من خلال خدمه
الكهرباء التي تم اصلاحها في عدد من
الاحياء نعم ابقى معنا السيد عمار وينضم
الينا في هذه التغطيه ايضا الدكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه السودانيه اهلا بك دكتور محمد يعني
وزاره الصحه السودانيه تحدثت اليوم وحذرت
من ان القطاع الصحي على وشك الانهيار كيف
يتجلى ذلك على الارض
لم تصرح وزاره الصحه ولا تخرطون بهذا
التصريح انا الناطق الرسمي
قال قال ذلك
الدوليه
كل مؤشرات لانهيار الوضع الصحي في السودان
يعني من اين استوى المعلومات
يعني كيف توصف الوضع الان مع خروج ع
المستشفيات دكتور محمد يعني مع خروج عده
مستشفيات من الخدمه والنقص بالمعدات
الطبيه والنهب الذي تتعرض له بعض
المستشفيات
لكل ما هو داخل المستشفيات كيف توصفها هل
هو مثالي يعني
تفضل تمثل 25% من سكان السودان ولاده
خرطوم تمثل واحد على 18 من الولايات
السودان يمتلك 711 مستشفى في السودان منها
133 مستشفى على القطاعين العام الخاص
بولايه الخرطون المستشفيات التي خرجت من
الخدمه عشر مستشفيات عامه في القطاع العام
وعشرين مستشفى القطاع الخاص عدد
المستشفيات التي خرجت لا تشكل لعبا على
على سير النظام الصحي لانه عدد الاسير
الموجود عندنا هو انا مستغل 30% من مغذيه
المستشرفات على تقديم الخدمات الصحيه يعني
وضع المستقبل
ات طبيه هناك وقود يصل الى المستشفيات
التردد الان في ظل تقديم الخدمه يساوي
0.2% من التردد الطبيعي في الاوقات
الطبيعيه وبالتالي
وبالتالي خروج المستشفيات عدد من
المستشفيات لان في مرمى النار لان
المسيفات غير امنه وتم تفريغها لمستشفيات
امنه بديله هذا لا لا ينذر بانهيار النظام
الصحي كما يقولون يعني
نعم ولكن دكتور محمد يعني هناك خوف كبير
للناس من الوصول حتى الى المستشفى في ظل
عدم وجود ممرات امنه لاسعاف
والنقل المصابين
نحن رفعنا مناشده عبر
عبر عبر الولايه والان وجدت استجابه من من
الجهات المعنيه
بالسماح لعربات الاسعاف بحريه التنقل
وحريه عبر عبر الجسور يعني والان
الاسعافات تتحرك مع بعض الضوابط الامنيه
يعني في مسار امني مؤمن لها
الاسعاف التي تنقل المرضى وتنقل الكوادر
بدينا في هذه الخطوات من اليوم ده كان ما
متوفر قبل اليومين السابقين في ظل في ظل
الازمه
ما صحه
المستشفيات الان التي تعمل كفيله بتقديم
الخدمات الصحيه كله كله ولكن هي كفيله
ولكن الهدنه يجب ان لا تخرى يستطيع
المواطنين الوصول ولكن اود ان اسالك عن
نقطه مهمه جدا هناك مخاوف من تفشي الاوبئه
بسبب وجود الجثث على هل رصدتم ذلك
نعمل انا اتحدث عن عن تقديم الخدمات في
المستشفيات
نعمين
نعم طيب هل من معلومات واحصاءات لديكم حول
اعداد
اللاعبين
اعداد المصابين مجمل ترددات المصابين 1572
مصاب ترديدات لحد صباح اليوم منذ الحرب
حتى صباح اليوم 1572 مصاب عدد الغتله 96
قتيل من مدني
لنظامي عددا نظامين القتلى المسجلين عندنا
عدد القتله المسجلين عندنا من من النظامين
12 يرجون المستشفيات من من الشقين يعني
القوات المسلحه والدعم عدد المصابين من
العسكريين 171 مصاب تمت معالجته وخرجوا من
المستشفى عدد العمليات التي تم اجراها في
القطاعين المسيفرات القطاع العام العامله
28 التي استقبلت جرحا 28 مستشفى عام
القطاع العام 19 مستشفى القطاع الخاص
استقبلت مرضى مش العامله اللي استقبلت
المرضى عدد العمليات التي اجرت حتى صباح
اليوم 300
عمليه كبيره لمتوسطه
امين عدد الجسامين الوصله المشارح ومسجله
سته 49 جثمان 41 جثمان تم تسليمه لذويهم
والان مجهولين الهويه تمنيه اربعه في
مشرحه مستشفى ام درمان واربعه في مستشفى
في مشرحه مستشفى هذه
العاده التي
في الشوارع في العاصمه الخرطوم وان تنفيت
ذلك
ولكننا نراها بام العين امامنا لم انفي
الجثث في الشوارع انا اتحدث عن الحالات
التي وصلت المستشفيات
تبحث عن تقديم الخدمات ولكن انت دكتور
اليس لديكم مخاوف من تفشل او بيئه
نعم لدينا لدينا مخاوف الان الغرفه
المركزيه تبحث مع جهاز تفصيلها في
وقت الهدنه في التخلص من
الجسد التي توجد في الطرقات
طيب ما هو وضع المشارح في السودان الان
في سابق
الخرطوم كانت بها
الخرطوم الان لدينا خمسه مشارح
في الخرطوم يعني الوضع المستقر في المشارح
يقابل على انها تستقبل الجسامين مجاهيل
الهويه المشرحه محدده هي مبدل نموذجي وهي
بتساعد 500
جسمان
ونبدل
النموذجي مستشفى
مشرحه مستشفى بشائر يعملون على قدم وثاق
يوجد هنالك تصريح للدفن الفوري للجسامين
معلومه الهويه طيب دكتور محمد يعني تحدث
بانه المستشفيات العامله الان كفيله
بتقديم الخدمات اللازمه ولكن فيما اذا
استمر هذا القتال المسلح وامتد امده هل
ستكون قادره على ذلك
في نحن في الغرفه المركزيه لدينا خطط
بديله اذا تعذر اذا تعذر اذا انا بقول اذا
تعذر تقديم الخدمات ولايه الخرطوم الولايه
قادره على التحويل للولايات المتاخمه
ولايات النيل الابيض مستقره ولايه الجزيره
مستغره ولايه نهر النيل مستقره ولايه
الشماليه مستقره نحن لدينا 711 مستشفى على
مستوى السودان
ولا تخافون وحدها تمتلك 15% من مجموعه
المستشفيات اللي هي 33 مستشفى
الكلام عن انهيار صحي وانهيار كذا كلام
يعني غير ما مبني على براهين يعني ولا على
دلائل
دكتور محمد يعني ذكرت بانه هناك عشرات
الجثث لم يتم التعرف عليها هل هناك من
اليه ربما تتبع بهكذا حالات يعني جهات
معينه من هي الجهه التي يجب على المواطن
الذهاب اليها لاجراء الفحوصات اللازمه
والتعرف على جثث ذويهم
هي المشارح المعروفه
الخرطوم كما ذكرتك لدينا خمسه مشارح
معروفه والمواطنين بيصبوا للمشاريح للتعرف
على الجسامين بالطول معهوده في طب الشرعي
شكرا
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
الدكتور محمد ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
تفاقمت ازمه مياه الشرب في الخرطوم بعد
مرور خمسه ايام على انقطاعها بالكامل عن
معظم المناطق السكنيه في الخرطوم حيث يعيش
السودانيون في ظروف صعبه بسبب انقطاع
المياه والكهرباء معا ما زاد من معاناتهم
بسبب نقص الغذائي وشرح الخدمات الاساسيه
فضلا عن خطوره الخروج عن المنازل بحثا
عنها في ظل استمرار الاشتباكات
ره
استخدموا لعبات الجوفيه والمعاناه كبيره
جدا درجه الحراره مرتفعه وانقطاع الكهرباء
ما بين فتره واخرى وانت كثير جدا من
الاحياء والمربعات المجاوره لجوا لنفس
الاتجاه والمنطقه بقت منطقه الناس بيكونوا
موجودين فيها وبياخدوا منها المياه
الجوفيه وهي المياه برده مش صالحه للشرب
غدر ما هي ممكن يتم استخدامها في اشياء
ثانيه
ونعود الى الكاتب الصحفي عمر ابو شيبه من
الخرطوم اهلا بك من جديد سيد عمار يعني ما
هو الدور المطلوب الان من الاحزاب المدنيه
ويعني الشعبيه الى حد كبير يعني ليس هنالك
من مبادره حقيقيه للتواصل مع الطرفين
لتهدئه الامور
يعني كانت هنالك مبادرات حتى قبل ان تبدا
هذه الحرب لعديد من القاده على المستوى
السياسي الموجودين يعني شاهدنا عديد من
البيانات حتى في صبيحه يوم السبت قبل
لحظات من بدء هذه الحرب ولكن يعني الحرب
تكون واقفه على رصاصه واحده ومن ثم يصعب
عمليه التواصل والتفاوض فيما يخص العمليات
العسكريه الان الحركيه معركه تكسير العظام
في مناطق كثيره جدا الجيش يستولي او يسترد
مناطق في وسط الخرطوم وفي ولايات اخرى ومن
ثم نشاهد عوده اخرى لقوات الدعم السريع
وتعود وتجدد الاشتباكات في ظل هدنه مطروحه
الان يظل عمليه التواصل وعمليه
المبادره التي تقدم من الاحزاب السياسيه
او الكيانات الاجتماعيه الان تعطل جدا
خاصه وان لغه السلاحيه اللغه الان
المنتشره والتي
نشاهد لها كثير جدا من الافعال على ارض
الواقع
تبقى عن مبادرات السياسيه الرهينه ايضا
كذلك بالضغوط الخارجيه التي يمكن ان توسم
في فتح الممرات سياسيه وفتح ممرات وافق
اوسع فيما يخص التواصل ما بين
الطرفين يعني ذلك قوى سياسيه يعني تناشد
وتدعو لضبط النفس وهنالك قوى سياسيه تناشر
الطرفين بان يهدئ وان يلجا الى عمليه
التفاوض ووضع السلاح
هذا في هذه اللحظه لان الجانب العسكري
الاخر
المضاف له يرون ان المعركه الان تحسن بشكل
العسكري وكانت هنالك عمليه سياسيه
للتهدئه متوقفه على يعني وقف اطلاق النار
او حتى هدنه لانه وزير الخارجيه وزير
خارجيه جنوب السودان تحديدا قال بانه توجه
وفد الايجاد الى الخرطوم يعتمد على وقف
اطلاق النار وايضا الضمانات الامنيه يعني
كيف يمكن لهذه المبادرات اللي كان
الاقليميه او الدوليه ان تاخذ مسارها في
عدم في ظل عدم يعني التزام الطرفين بساعات
ب 24 ساعه فقط من الهدنه
هذا ما يؤكد حديث ان العمليه السياسيه في
الداخل ربما
ذهبت الى يعني
ذهبت بلا عوده
لاتفاق الايطالي او الحديث عن عمليه
سياسيه ويعني شقي العمليه السياسيه من
الجانب العسكري الان يتقاتلان الجيش يرى
بانها قوه متمرده عليه ويوجد حتمها والعكس
صحيح يعني يصعب عمليه التواصل السياسي او
يصعب حتى طرح مبادره سياسيه في ظل الراهن
هكذا لكن الضغوط الخارجيه يمكن ان تسهم في
تقليل حده الصراع يمكن ان تفتح مسارا
جديدا خاصه
اذا ايام اكثر في في عمر هذه الحرب دخلنا
الان يمكن لليوم السادس من عمر هذه الحرب
كثير من البيانات يعني الجيش يتهم الدعم
السريع بانه خرقوا الهدنه والعكس صحيح
يبقى عمليه الضغوط الخارجيه التي يمكن ان
تسهل نوعا ما في تهدئه الاوضاع في السودان
قائمه ولكن بحذر يعني شاهدنا قبل قليل او
قبل ساعات ان قوه سلمت الجنود المصريين
الذين كانوا بحوزتها هذا الاتجاه ربما
يفتح ابواب التفاوض او ربما يفتح ابواب
نوعا ما من عديد من مبادرات حتى على
المستوى الافريقي والنصر مؤثره في ذلك او
حتى على المستوى الاموي اوروبي شكرا جزيلا
لك سيد عمار ابو شيبه الكاتب الصحفي من
الخرطوم بحريه
وسط القذائف والقصف اثر انزلاق القتال بين
الجيش ودعم السريع منذ خمسه ايام تتفجر
الازمات الانسانيه بالسودان واحده تلو
الاخرى
بعد غروب الشمس تتناول هذه الاسره
السودانيه الفاتوره في لحظه صمت تنقطع فيه
اصوات المدافع ويرتفع صوت الاذان في
استراحه قصيره من الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
الضائقه الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها السودان
منذ سنوات يسعى المواطنون لتجاهلها ولو
مؤقتا على مائده الافطار حيث باتت واقعا
يؤرقهم لا يمكنهم توقع تبعاته في ظل
القتال المحتدم
وبالرغم من انهم ربما تجاهلوا بشكل مؤقت
مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الا نزمات الغذاء التي
تلوح في الافق اصبحت حقيقه واقعه في
السودان استمرار القتال تسبب في تفاقم
الوضع الانساني المتازم بالفعل 15 مليون
شخص بالكاد تتوفر لديهم مستلزمات الغذاء
الاساسيه بحسب تقرير للامم المتحده تقارير
اخرى تشير الى ان نحو اربعه ملايين طفل
دون الخامسه يعانون من بوادر سوء التغذيه
المعارك الدائره حاليا الحقت اضرارا
مباشره في البنيه التحتيه عائلات بالكامل
استبدلت المشروبات الرمضانيه بالمياه
بعدما استهدفت محطات المياه في بعض
الاحياء مثل بحر شمالي الخرطوم
عائلات اخرى لجات الى الاكتفاء بوجبه
واحده فقط في اليوم في سبيل التعايش مع
الظروف الصعبه
الاحياء الاوفر حظا يقتنص سكانها فرصه
هدوء الاشتباكات ليهرعوا الى محلات
البقاله ليجدوا ارففها فارغه تماما خاصه
التي تحتوي على المياه المعدنيه
اغلب الاحتياجات نقدر نجيبه بالنسبه
لاغلاق الطعم لسوبر ماركت والدكاكين
السيناريو الاكثر سوءا الذي لم يتوقعه
السودانيون كان اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي وقفه مساعداته للبلاد على وقع
مقتل ثلاثه من موظفيه نتيجه الاشتباكات
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم كيف هو الوضع الان في
العاصمه
مره اخرى كذلك في الساعه الماضيه هنا في
مدينه بحري في منطقه كافوري مربع سته في
ذات المكان الذي فيه معسكر الدعم السريع
هناك
دعوات جاءت من الاليه الرباعيه وكذلك من
حالبين على موضوع الهدنه كذلك غير الالياف
الرباعيه
تحدثوا اعنا انه يجب ان تحترم الاطراف
بصوت القذائف والاشتباكات يا سالم وانت
تتحدث
نعم هذه في قلب العاصمه الخصوم بالقرب من
القياده العامه للجيش
نعم نعم
باي مراكز ونقاط تتركز هذه الاشتباكات
المتقطعه
تكون دائما
بالقرب من القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
كذلك في منطقه بحري في كارفوري وكذلك في
القرب من جسر كمبات الرابط بينه بحري وام
درمان كذلك في ام درمان في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون
ايضا سمعت اصوات الرصاص كذلك
متكرره
وايضا اصوات لمدافع كذلك في المهندسين في
منطقه المهندسين
سالم هل استفاد الناس من هذه الهدنه
لا اظن ان هناك فائده واضحه حتى الان
من مساء اليوم
لكن
ننتظر حتى الصباح لتتضح معالم هذه الامه
سالم يعني حتى يعني على الاقل
بالهدنه السابقه كانت تبدا الساعه السادسه
بتوقيت الخرطوم اي ليلا يعني ذلك يدعو الى
القلق يعني اصلا بغض النظر انه ليس هنالك
يعني
هل يخاف الناس حتى لو كان هناك هدنه من
الذهاب لتامين المؤن او الذهاب الى
المستشفيات
نعم هذه ايضا من الامور التي نالت نقاشا
في اوساط الشارع السوداني في توقيت الهدنه
هناك من قال ان الهدنه كان الاولى منذ
الصباح حتى يستطيع المسافرون ان يسافروا
في وقت كافل لان الكثير من الذين كانوا
ينتظرون
هذه الهدنه كانوا ينتظرونها من اجل ان
يغادروا الخرطوم الى الولايات القريبه
والمتاخمه في ولايه الخرطوم
الابيضات الجزيره او حتى نهر النيل او
الشماليه حتى
في غالب هؤلاء الناس يتحدثون عن هذه
الهدنه من اجل ان يسافروا هنا يجب ان
نتحدث عن هذا السفر كذلك انه ليس من اجل
هذه الحرب لوحدها ليست السبب الوحيد في
سفرهم اعتاد السودانيون كذلك في مع خواتيم
شهر رمضان وبدايه عيد
سالم ماذا يمكن القول حول مواقع سيطره كل
طرف يعني هل تم الحسم بانه هذه النقطه
مثلا تابعه للجيش سيطر عليها بشكل كامل
ونقطه اخرى سيطر عليها سيطرت عليها قوات
الدعم السريع هل هنالك حسم
قال الجيش السوداني انه سيطره على القياده
العامه للجيش وانها تحت امرته وسيطره
وايضا هناك
مناطق اخرى تحدثت دعم السريع على انها تحت
سيطرته وتحت امراته كذلك لكن يبقى المحبه
في اثبات هذه الامور
نعم نعم بينه والاخرى نستمع الى هذه
الطلقات في قلب العاصمه الخرطوم ليس ببعيد
من القياده العامه للجيش
لم يتم الالتزام بهذه الهدنه بين طرفي
الحرب او هذا النزاع المسلح في السودان
كما نستمع مشاهدينا نسمع بين الحين والاخر
اصوات لطلقات قذائف احيانا تكون يعني قويه
جدا واحيانا لا
مراسل العربيه يعني كان اكد بانه
الاشتباكات متقطعه وهي تجريبي محيط
القياده العامه وايضا الخرطوم بحري ماذا
عن باقي النقاط يعني سالم غير محيط
القياده العامه
نعم غير محيط القياده العامه
ومحيطه للاذاعه والتلفزيون كذلك في كابول
كل هذه المناطق ما زالت تشهد اطلاق
المتقطعا
للنار وكذلك اصوات للمدافع
كان منذ قليل سالم معنا يعني متحدث
من الصحه السودانيه كان طمانه بشكل كبير
بانه المستشفيات العامله الان بالبلاد لا
تزال قادره على تقديم الخدمات اللازمه
للمواطنين ونحن نشاهد اصلا حتى لو كان
ليلا سحب للدخان
تصاحب طلقات واصوات قذائف قويه ترتفع
حدتها بين الفين والاخرى سالم وضع
المستشفيات الان
وايضا المؤن الغذائيه هل هي متوفره في
المتاجر
هذه هي الامور التي كانت ينبغي الهدنه او
كانت التحدي للهدنه ان وجدت موضوع المواد
الغذائيه وامدادها وتوفير الممر
بمرور هذه المساعدات وكذلك توفير هذه
الممرات الامنه كذلك لمرور كوادر الطبيه
للمستشفيات ووصول الامدادات الطبيه لها
كذلك كل هذه تحديات مهمه كانت تنتظر هذه
الهدنه لكن يظهر ان الهدنه غير موجوده
شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي وكنا استمعنا
منذ قليل لتجدد الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في الخرطوم بحري
وايضا حول القياده العامه
نشاهد قبل يعني ان نشاهد هذا العرض التالي
نشاهد نيرانا تتصاعد على الشاشه
يعني جهه الشمال هناك دخان وهناك نيران
بالخلفيه خلفيه الصوره
يعني لا نعلم هذه النقطه ما هي بالتحديد
ولكن اغلب الاشتباكات الساخنه كانت تحصل
بمحيط القياده العامه وايضا القصر
الجمهوري ومعلوم القصر الجمهوري رمزيته
بالنسبه
للسودانيين اذا رغم الهدنه مشاهدينا لا
نزال نسمع اصوات للاشتباكات بالعاصمه
الخرطوم
وكانت الاليه الثلاثيه
المكونات طبعا من الاتحاد الافريقي
والايجاد والامم المتحده اصدرت بيان يعني
تتحدث فيه عن وقف اطلاق النار وعن هدنه
لمده 24 ساعه في السودان والطرفي طرفي
النزاع التزم بها او قلاء انهما سيلتزمان
بها ولكن الصور واصوات الاشتباكات تقول
عكس ذلك
العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي
[موسيقى]
مروي من ابرز اسماء المدن السودانيه التي
تصدرت عناوين الاخبار خلال الايام الماضيه
نتعرف على المدينه واهميتها بشكل اكبر في
هذا التقرير
محاور عده للنزاع في السودان من ابرزها ما
يدور في العاصمه لكن الاعين تتوجه ايضا
لمنطقه اخرى الى اكبر ولايات السودان
الولايه الشماليه التي برز من بين مدنها
بشكل لافت مروي الواقعه على بعد 350
كيلومترا شمال العاصمه الخرطوم المدينه
ذات اهميه عسكريه كبيره ازدادت مع الصراع
الحالي بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع جل
التركيز صب على مطار المدينه للجانبين
المدني والعسكري وتضاربت الانباء حول
الجانب المسيطر عليه الى ان اعلن الجيش عن
اعاده السيطره على مطار مروي المطار يعتبر
قاعده جويه مسانده ومنطقه تمركز بديله
للقواعد العسكريه الاخرى في السودان ويغطي
مطارها العمليات الجويه في شمال السودان
وشرقه وغربه اهميه مطار مروي تتاتى من
كونه احد اكبر المطارات في افريقيا فهو
يقع على مساحه 18 كيلوم ترا وهو مصمم
لاستيعاب هبوط واقلاع الطائرات الضخمه
بمهبط طائرات بطول حوالي اربعه كيلو مترات
وعرض 60 مترا وفي مطار مروي ومحيطه تنتشر
قوات الفرقه تسعه عشر التابعه للجيش
السوداني المسؤوله عن حمايه المرافق
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
وانضم الينا من القاهره احمد عليبه الباحث
في وحده الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك معنا سيد احمد يعني
لا حسم حتى اليوم نحن امام معارك فيها كر
وفر لا احد من الطرفين يستطيع القول بانه
انا سيطرت على هذه النقطه هل نحن امام
معركه لن تحسم اصلا
تحياتي لحضراتكم شكرا على الاستضافه اولا
يعني تعودنا من الصراعات التي نشاهدها على
مستوى الدوله على المستوى الاقليمي
الصراعات المحليه الموجوده او الصراعات
الاهليه او الصراعات المسلحه الا نراهن
على سيناريو سريع للتنبؤ بما يمكن ان يجري
لانه في حقيقه الامر كل حاله من هذه
الحالات قدمت معطيات مختلفه هناك فيما
يتعلق بالسودان كما ذكرت حضرتك ايضا هناك
تطور في حاله الاشتباك ما بين الطرفين
بدات في اليوم الاول بشكل اختلف عن
اليومين التاليين اليوم ايضا تدخل في
المنعطف اخر وهو التركيز على العاصمه
الخرطوم بشكل او باخر المساله الاخرى هي
انه لابد ان ننظر قبل اي سيناريو
المستقبلي الى معطيات الوضع الصوتي نحن في
السودان يعني وضع السودان اولا لم يتعافى
من
[موسيقى]
دون الاخر على هذه النقاط الثلاثه ماذا
يعني ذلك
انا اعتقد انه سيحاول اي طرف ان هو يسيطر
على هذه المواقع التاكيد على ان هو حسب
المعركه في الخرطوم لكن هل حسم المعركه في
الخرطوم معناه ان المعركه حصلت بشكل شامل
انا لا اتصور ذلك وما بعد الحسم في
الخرطوم كيف سيكون المصري هل يستطيع من
يصل او القصر الجمهوري في ظل انه لا عمليه
سياسيه الان ولا توجد دوله او عفوا وصل
السودان الى حاله الله دوله بمفهوم
السياسي او بالمنطق السياسي ايضا هل من
الممكن ان يكون تغلب اي طرف على الاخر
معناه انه سوف يرسم خريطه الطريق الى
المستقبل انا اعتقد انه اولا سوف تكون
هناك معضلات عسكريه في الهيمنه لذا حتى ما
تم الحسم على هذه المواقع لانه ما هو
المستهدف الطرفان يتبادلان الحديث عن
التخلص من الاخر يعني قياده ترى بان وجود
القياده الاخرى يشكل لها تهديد وجودي
وبالتالي الان كلا يرى انه يتعين عليه ان
يلغي وجود اخر لكن الا اذا يمهد الهيمنه
هل هذا يمهد الى مسار سياسي يمكن ان ينقل
السودان من هذا المشهد الى مشهد مستقر انا
اعتقد انه ايضا هذا الامر من الصعب ايضا
ان نتكهن بما سوف يصل على لكن انا في
تقديري ان المشهد يتحرك من السيء الى
الاسوء رغم انه الحديث عن بعض انفراجات
تتعلق ربما
بمحاوله الاستماع الى مبادرات للتهدئه لكن
هدى لا تصمد تصعيد لا يزال مستمر وتبادل
رسائل ما بين الطرفين مع القوه الوسيطه
بانه من الواضح انه لا استجابه لعمليه وقف
اطلاق النار ولا استجابه للاذن القصيره
يمكن ان تتحول اليهود طويل الضغط المطلوب
لايقاف هذه الحرب ووضع اليه حسم للمواجهات
هل هنالك اصلا اليه حسم لايقاف كل ما يحصل
اليه الحاسم بالشكل الخاص بهيكل القوى
العسكريه غير والده في هذه الحاله لانه
يبدو ان هناك نوع من التعادل حتى لو كان
هيكل الميزان القلعه العسكريه بالنسبه
للجيش اكبر لكن قوه الدعم السريع ايضا
لديها القدره على التكتيك المناوره
واستمرار التصعيد المساله هنا لن يحسم هذا
الامر لكن من يعني من اي لحظه يمكن ان
يبدا التراجع يبدا التراجع حينما يحس طرفه
ويدرك طرف بانه
لم يعد ميزان القويمين لصالحه وبالتالي
يتعين عليه ان يخرج بشكل يؤمن له العوده
مره اخرى الى مسارات تكون مختلفه عن
المسارات السيئه التي يمكن ان تحكم مصيره
النقطه الاخرى ان يكون هناك نوع من
الاختراق الدولي القابل بالفعل للتاثير
على الاطراف وهذه المساله ايضا هي محل جدل
لانه هناك تناقضات فيما يتعلق بالتدخل
الدولي هناك بعض الرسائل تقول ان التدخل
الدولي قد يكون سلبيا لانه هناك بعض
الاطراف بدات تظهر في المشهد مجموعه وما
الى ذلك يعني التطور هذه الامور قد يعقد
التدخل الدوله ومع ذلك تظل للامم المتحده
لمجلس الامن حتى الاليات الاقليميه لايجاد
الاتحاد الافريقي الجامعه العربيه يعني
هذه المبادرات الى حد ما تحاول على الاقل
ان توجه دعوه ربما يستلقتها احد الاطراف
في مرحله من المراحل النقطه الاخرى هي
اللحظه التي يبدا عندها التحول للخروج من
هذا المشهد وهي اللحظه التي يرى فيها
بالفعل انه طرف ليس عليه الا ان يتوقف او
يتراجع اذا ما دخلنا الى منعطف اخر بمعنى
سقوط عدد كبير من المدنيين لن يسمح
بالمجتمع الدولي ولا تستطيع اي ولا يستطيع
اي طرف من الطرفين ان يتحمل المسؤوليه عنه
بشكل او باخر او ان يحدث نوع من الانهيار
في الصفوف او ان يحدث يعني نوع من
الازمه في السودان ستمتد اثارها الى خارج
حدوده دعنا اذا نشاهد ابعاد هذه الحرب
المصغره ثم نستكمل حوارنا
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخرت لها طالما ان
الجنرالين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او ديفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرالين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فباي ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
من جديد اعود اليك سيد احمد علي بالبحث في
وحدات الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام هل تتخوف من امتداد هذه الحرب وان
يكون لها تاثير سلبي واضح على المحيط
الاقليمي كان اليوم الجيش السوداني تحدث
عن انه المسلحين الذين لجاوا لتشاد يتبعون
للدعم السريع ولكن ليس هنالك من مناوشات
يعني بالتاكيد سوف يكون هناك انعكاس
لتداعيات هذه الحرب سيظهر في تاثيرات او
في صور عديده جزء منها ما اشرت اليه حضرتك
انه مساله عدم ضبط الحدود بالشكل الكافي
والمطلوب فيما يتعلق
لاسيما الحدود الغربيه في السودان مع
اتشاد وايضا الغربيه من الجهه الشماليه مع
ليبيا في ظل الاوضاع الموجوده سواء في
ارشاد او الموجوده في ليبيا رغم انه كان
هناك تعويل في المرحله السابقه من خلال
لجنه خمس زائد خمسه العسكريه في اللقاء في
القاهره وفي لقاءات في طرابلس وبنجازي على
ترتيب الاوضاع الخاصه
بالنشر قوه المشتركه في الجنوب ايضا في
تشاد كان هناك تصريح من وزير الدفاع
التشادي ايضا بانه اتشاد غير معنيه بهذه
المساله رغم انه هذا التصريح يعني بيطرح
علامه استفه النظر الى التدخل الاثني
والعلاقات القائمه ما بين الحدود خاصه
فيما يتعلق بقوات الدعم السريع المتصور
هنا انه ايضا هذه البيئه هشه الى حد كبير
يعني البيئه الاقليميه هشه الى حد كبير
وبالتالي التاثيرات المتبادله فيها سواء
فيما يتعلق به صراع مسلح او الجريمه
المنظمه العابره للحدود او
تهريب السلاح او عبور مقاتلين انا اعتقد
ان كل هذه المظاهر هي عوامل قد تشكل ظواهر
اذا امتدت هذه الحرب وبالتالي المطلوب هو
ان يكون هناك سيناريو سريع لانهاء هذه
الحرب وان تكون دول الجوار حريصه
[موسيقى]
السوداء من اطرافه ما شكل هذا السيناريو
يعني انا اتصور انه على الاقل هذا
السيناريو يحتاج الى عاملين العامل الاول
ان يكون هناك الحد الادنى من التوافق
الدولي والاقليمي على هدوء الاوضاع في
السودان واعاده الامور الى حاله الاستقرار
حاله الاستقرار التي تعني قبول الطرفين
بوقف اطلاق النار ثم العوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات هذا الامر سوف يستغرق بعض الوقت
المساله الاخرى ان يكون هناك ايضا تلاقي
اراده داخليه ما بين الطرفين للتعامل مع
مثل هذه المبادرات انا يعني في تصوري انه
هذا السيناريو ربما يكون واردا في
المستقبل اذا بالفعل ادرك الاطراف انه
مساله الحسم العسكري هي صعبه بالفعل كل
النماذج الاقليميه في الصراعات اوضحت حرب
ليبيا في اربعه ابريل عام 2019 اكدت على
هذا الامر انه لا يمكن لطرف ان يحسن
السرافي الاخير ذهب الطرفان الى طاوله
المفاوضات واصبحت الان هناك يعني ربما
قواسم مشتركه ومصالح مشتركه ما بين
الاطراف الدخول الى عمليه سياسيه جاده
المساله الاخرى انه ايضا لابد ان يكون
مفهوما انه لا يستطيع اي طرف ان يحصل اخر
من المشهد نحن لا نتحدث عن قوه قوامها
مئات الافراد مثلا بالنسبه للدعم السريع
نحن نتحدث عن قوه قوامها عشرات الالاف من
الافراد لديها امكانيات عسكريه كبيره ايضا
بالنسبه للجيش هذا جيش نظامي لا يمكن ان
يلغى من المعادله بشكل او باخر المساله
الاخرى ان تكون هناك ترتيبات واضحه
يرتديها كل الاطراف جزء من هذه الترتيبات
ان يتم تحديد السلاح تحيدها هذه الاطراف
من العمليه السياسيه بالشكل المقبول بمعنى
ان تعود الامور الى قاعده صحيحه بان تكون
المهمه الوظيفيه للقوات المسلحه هي تتعلق
بمساله الدفاع ايضا تقويه العامل المدني
العامل السياسي المدني الذي ايضا يعني
يقع عليه جزء من المسؤوليه صحيح انه يعني
لا يتعان علينا ان ن المثاليين لنقول انه
المساله او الوضع بالنسبه للقوى السياسيه
هو افضل وانه لكن على الاقل على الاقل
هناك يعني ما هو مامول من هذا السياق بانه
يقال مدنيه ايضا طرفي المرحله الحاليه
صحيح ان يعني انها يعني يعني لم تاخذ
مبادره مقنعه لدى الاطراف لانه الوضع صعب
لكن انا بتصور انه على الاقل لابد ان تكون
هناك رساله بهذا الشكل لانه الشعب
السوداني هو من يدفع تكلفه هذا الصراع في
الاخير هو صراع عسكري من قوه عسكريتين كل
سيد احمد عليبه على ارائك البحث في وحده
الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات الاستراتيجيه والسياسيه
وقال صالح حسن احمد مدير مطار مروي الدولي
ان المطار تعرض لضرر كبير نتيجه
الاشتباكات التي كانت متواصله داخل وفي
محيط المطار والقاعده الجويه العسكريه
خلال الايام الماضيه
الوضع الان تدمير شديد جدا لمنشات ومرافق
المطار ومتتابعون يعني
تدمير شديد جدا في المرفقات وهذه المرفقات
كانت شركه مطارات السودان لحدي وبال هذه
الاحداث بعشره 15 يوم تسعه لترخيص هذا
المطار يعني الخطه كانت بنهايه هذا العام
او قبال مطار مروي الدولي ينال شهاده
ترخيص اللي هي كفاءه التشغيل الدوليه من
سلطه الطيران المدني عشان يصبح مطار مناوب
ويصبح مطار بديل يا اخواننا ودايرين في
دراسات لتشغيل الصادر والله المطار طبعا
درجات المطار الان احنا لسه ما يعني في
اطار في اطار
التفقد للمنشات ولكن نبشر الناس يعني ان
شاء الله نحن حسب حسب خبرتنا في في مجال
الطيران المدني اخواننا المطاري ان شاء
الله قلب المطار هو المدرج يعني انا ما
اعتقد انه المدرج حصل له اضرار يعني
اذا باخر التحديثات حول العسكريين
المصريين الذين
احتجز في مروي الجيش السوداني الان يعلن
اجلاء 177 جنديا مصريا كانوا محتجزين في
مروي من قبل الدعم
السريع عبر اربع طائرات عسكريه مصريه
من مطار دونجل اذا حصلت عمليه الاجلاء
للجنود المصريين
قال وزير الدفاعة شادي داودايايا ابراهيم
في تصريحاته العربيه ان الجيش التشدي او
قفا فرقه سودانيه تضم 400 عسكري سوداني
دخلت الحدود وقال وزير الدفاع تشاد ان هذه
الفرقه دخلت الى البلاد بحثا عن الامان
مشيرا الى ان الاقتتال في السودان خلق
موجه جديده من اللاجئين مما سيصعب مهمه
تامين الحدود
جانبه اكد متحدث رسمي باسم الجيش السوداني
المسلحين الذين لجاوا الى تشاد تابعين
لقوات الدعم السريع ولا علاقه لهم بالجيش
واضاف المتحدث ان جنود الجيش السوداني
بمواقعهم على الحدود التشاديه ولا يوجد اي
مناوشات
تغطيه العربيه لهذا النزاع المسلح في
السودان مستمره مع الزميله ميسون ويتفضلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات